if you suddenly woke up in a
post-apocalyptic future what would you
do the world as you know it has been
destroyed had everything Left Alive is
out to kill you I'm going to break down
for mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the Apocalypse in seven
seeds this girl doesn't realize that
Japan is about to become an underwater
death trap Natsu here wakes up scared
and confused as hell just as this woman
busts in and tells her that the ship
thereon is sinking Natsu doesn't know
how she got here she follows the woman
outside to a life raft but she is not
the only one cold and scared to the Bone
these survivors can't remember how or
when they got here but they suddenly
spot a scary looking island in the
distance and they decide to make
landfall but they have no idea what
horrifying monsters they're about to see
reaching the island they decide to all
introduce themselves starting with the
nice guy arashi followed by acai who
tries to get creepily close to Natsu in
order to become friends and this
mysterious woman who says her name is
botan and declares herself as leader
because she's the oldest and orders the
group to begin looking for fresh water
and food and shortly thereafter she
tells a scared little Natsu here that if
she doesn't pull her weight this island
will kill her before she knows it
elsewhere this other Survivor Hana here
runs for her dear life as she gets
chased by an army of carnivorous beetles
she finally manages to escape and catch
her breath and get some water when
suddenly she turns around and sees a
massive mutated praying mantis ready to
Feast on her flesh and it tries to kill
her she prepares to die right here but
is suddenly saved by this ponytail guy
and the group quickly works together to
kill the rest of the monsters okay this
is nuts we have seen too much crazy [ __ ]
to make me think that we are just on a
regular Island this creature looks like
a praying mantis that is literally more
than double our size which clearly means
the nut everything is as it seems if we
were to assume that this creature is
similar and possibly within the same
family tree as the Mantis and insect
family then we can assume that this
thing is similar in its characteristics
and structure as them and this means
we're in trouble because the praying
mantis is more of a methodical killer
than most people realize predatory
animals are normally divided into two
categories based on how they catch their
prey the first ones are known as the
pursuit of predators like cheetahs or
robber Flies who chase down their prey
they're more flashy and they're
basically the famous superstars of the
animal world but then you have the
second group known as the sit and wait
Predators these creatures usually have
hunt patterns that are similar to a
wind-up toy they sit and perform the
same action over and over however
praying mantises are a different
horrifying breed because they can adapt
to catch their prey by varying their
strike speed and can calculate how fast
they need to be in order to catch their
prey they can strike at a speed of 60
milliseconds but here's the thing folks
this creature is not like most other
Predators out there because unlike those
things this bug has one written rule
hard etched into its DNA that I think we
can use and that is the fact that this
creature only eats live prey meaning
Hana here as soon as she spotted this
bug in the corner of her eye should not
have moved an inch because all of her
movement and being all Higgly Piggly and
moving around caused her to become more
of a tasty snack in the eyes of this
horrifying monster and this is in tune
with how certain species of larva
survive when predatory birds like donex
accidentally drop them after grabbing
them out of their sand pits the moment
of The larva falls from the bird's grasp
it plays dead on the floor in order to
make the bird think that it would be way
too much of an effort to go back for it
and instead would rather get more food
somewhere else this type of resource
management system ingrained in certain
Wildlife means that Hana should not have
moved and played dead initially which
would then ideally not aggravate the
praying mantis and keep things calm long
enough for her friends to show up and
save her which by the way they were not
that far behind to begin with but
regardless Hana here was way too
Carefree about how she acted and this is
likely gonna cost her very soon after
killing the horde of Monsters the group
heads back to their base just like Natsu
and her survivors hana's group can't
remember how they got here only that
it's been two weeks since they woke up
and now they're running out of supplies
old green shirt guy here then declares
himself as the leader through physical
dominance and then demands that they
leave this island in search of help and
he isn't taking no for an answer later
that night the group then leaves by boat
but this island has other plans for them
and suddenly everyone here gets swept up
in a storm just as they arrive right
back to where they started on this
horrifying Island and now there's a sea
of eyes all looking at them scared and
angry old green shirt guy tries to grab
this comatose little injured girl and
use her as bait but Hana protects her
and makes this guy trip and fall right
into this swarm of bugs thinking he's
dead they leave old green shirt guy to
his doom and that was their biggest
mistake they head back to their
Shipwrecked boat to look for supplies
that they can use when suddenly they
hear footsteps of someone approaching
it's old green shirt guy and he's alive
and he just acts like everything is
Handy Dandy and tells the group that
he's found shelter and leads a group
deep into the dark jungle but Hana here
can tell that something is terribly
wrong meanwhile back at Camp Natsu she
thinks their leader botan knows more
than she's letting on everything that
this lady has done has been way too calm
and collected she's been way too
prepared and knows exactly what to do in
every single situation they've been in
Natsu tells arashi here that she thinks
she could be one of the people that
kidnapped them he tells her to pack up
her things and the two suddenly leave
the camp before anyone notices and that
was a big mistake this island is out to
kill them and suddenly arashay gets
swiped up by a giant man eating Vitus
fly trap Natsu tries to help by getting
him a knife but suddenly another giant
plant traps her up too terrified for her
life Natsu thinks she's going to die but
all of a sudden this mysterious stud
glasses guy saves both of them right as
botan and long hair guy run into them as
well I already asks what the hell is
going on and botan and glasses guy
finally tell them the horrifying truth
okay what this is horrifying because
this not only means that everyone we
once knew is likely dead but also that
all of our Creature Comforts are gone
and that means no Chick-fil-A no Burger
King no ps5s that sucks but aside from
all that there is one way we can get a
rough idea of how long these guys have
been in cryosleep and that is by looking
at the giant monsters all around them
because if we've noticed a lot of these
creatures that have tried to kill us so
far are two to three times our size
which means that the Flora and Fauna of
the Earth all the bugs even the large
Venus flytrap that tried to kill us that
was fun all of these things had enough
time to change since the meteor
destroyed Earth and they all adapted to
a new and ruthless climate this is what
likely caused a species-sized shift in
response to all of this due to the
environmental factors and of course
genetic drift which is like natural
selection but a process more random in
nature which causes a new population to
show up and can be genetically different
than the original population growing
larger to cope in a more unforgiving
environment is also an evolutionary
theory that many believe and reason why
many of the animals of the past like the
dinosaurs were so much bigger than the
animals of today but for the world's
species to grow to such sizes would take
millions of years of adaptation
according to the evolutionary theory and
according to that theory they all
happened after an Extinction event of
which there have been five Extinction
events in total and with the Earth just
recently being livable again in terms of
the Earth's history could help explain
why there are no insanely large
creatures on Earth in our timeline as of
yet as it simply takes time for such
creatures to adapt to such sizes and if
we were to look at how long it took for
life to re-emerge after the dinosaurs
got wiped out then that means it has
been at least thirty thousand years
since the current meteor destroyed our
planet but factor in the large Wildlife
at this current point then that size
difference would have likely taken an
additional 5 million years on top of the
30 000 years for all this to take place
long story short it's safe to say that
these people are more in the future than
they'd like to be which means everything
they've ever known has changed and not
in a good way back in Hannah's group
they continue to follow old green shirt
guy deeper and deeper into the forest
and finally into this dark tunnel but
this girl notices his hand twitch and
realizes that her gut was right
something is horribly wrong suddenly his
face begins exploding with worms and the
group is surrounded by a horde of
praying mantises this was all a trap
right as all hope appears lost old green
shirt guy breaks free from his bug mind
control and tells them to find another
team that was put into cryosleep
somewhere under Tokyo and to head to the
seven Fuji landmarks in order to survive
he then brutally barbecues himself
scaring off the giant bugs and saving
this group after mourning for the old
man for about 10 seconds anime style the
group builds a new life raft and decides
to head off to one of the landmarks
closest to them to find more survivors
and answers elsewhere Natsu's group is
led by botan to find a Survivor seed
Vault that will give them supplies and
food but suddenly they hear screams
coming from nearby and end up saving
more stranded survivors this
black-haired kit pink shirt girl and
this girl who looks like she sadly got
two meatball hair buns in her hair
meatball hair girl but they don't have
time for names when drama queen Natsu
discovers the most insane thing nearby
and discovers that the sea around them
is actually a lake she tells botan that
the water isn't salty meaning that if
they take a boat off of this island they
may find more land and one of the seed
vaults and so the group quickly builds
and sets sail off of a makeshift life
raft stopping by this piece of land when
they discover a landmark in the water
that tells them that they've reached
Nagasaki botan then tells them that
they're close to finding one of the
seven storage shelters spread out over
Japan's several Fuji mountains the group
continues to hike mile after mile until
they finally reach a Dusty door leading
them into one of the seven seed vaults
here they find Food Supplies and
everything they need to rebuild Society
okay this is insane they've just
uncovered a massive seed Vault that has
everything they need to survive and this
vault is not unlike a real Vault known
around the world today as the Doomsday
vault which is located above the Arctic
Circle between Norway and the North Pole
this place houses more than 930 000
varieties of food crop designed to save
as much of the world's agricultural
biodiversity on the off chance any large
or small doomsday scenarios take place
around the world this means that Natsu's
group has essentially found their Garden
of Eden their most important survival
asset and they should defend this asset
at all costs however just as important
as what's in front of them what's around
them also needs to be taken into account
if they want to survive properly it's
noted that they traveled past Nagasaki
initially and eventually arrived at
Mount Fuji this area is a sacred place
that houses 33 active volcanoes and is
surrounded by five beautiful lakes and
this is the exact reason or at least a
very likely reason that this seed Vault
was placed near this Mount as the
groundwater located in these parts is
suitable for drinking water and can be
found in abundance if I were these
survivors I would cut my losses and
forget about anyone else that that I
think might be a lie and start focusing
on developing this place as a
functioning Fortress however badass
botan already knew about this place and
it was located most likely on purpose
right under a significant Landmark this
statue which means it was meant to be
discovered and won't be long before more
survivors start showing up since
everyone likely got the same set of
information as us but if there is
anything that we have learned from The
Walking Dead and other shows like it
it's that people can be real turd
blossoms during the apocalypse which
means I would start finding ways to
Decay and hide any of these landmarks
such as this statue and also the seed
vault door we gotta cover that up
somehow we can begin the decaying
process of the statue Itself by planting
seeds like the Douglas Moss which can
take root within the Rock and cause
cracks and crevices within it and we
also should have no problem finding such
seeds due to the fact that we're right
next to a freaking seed Vault this in
turn will eventually destroy the
landmark and any indication to anyone
else that there is a seed Vault within
this location because this Vault will no
doubt cause them trouble sooner than
they think botan pushed the group to
work to rebuild Society but arashi says
that he's going to look for his family
in Tokyo in the meantime Natsu decides
to join him and the two head off
traveling high and low for days but one
day during their trip they hear a
strange sound coming from the bushes
they prepare to fight another horrifying
bug when suddenly long hair guy falls
out he tells them that since botan was
being too bossy he's run away to come
join them the three then continue on
their Journey when they surprisingly
arrive at a thriving settlement on the
way but they don't realize that this
place will show them no mercy this
farmer suddenly spots them and tells
them to get out of here quick but just
then these two Village Lords show up and
they aren't your ordinary survivors
Natsu and her friends discovered that
this group is run by tyrants having
woken up three years earlier these
people have created this Village Through
Blood Sweat and Tears and more blood
punishing anyone who doesn't pull their
weight aoreshi says that they're just
passing through on the way to Tokyo but
this Village Lord guy thinks they're
here to steal food so he he ties them up
however their luck turns sweet as
they're saved by this villager tan face
guy who helps them escape the village
and onto this boat and they continue on
with their Journey eventually reaching
Tokyo they see the once glorious City
now in complete ruins arashi is
devastated and thinks his missing
girlfriend who wasn't that important to
the story anyways is down there and he
jumps in right into this Monster's House
suddenly this giant fish attacks him
shocking everyone as this is the first
fish they've seen so far prepared to die
this fish pounces right above arushi
until the creature gets killed by this
ponytail guy the group is shocked but
they get even more horrified when
ponytail guy here says that he's been
awake for over 15 years and that he's
the only one from his group Left Alive
arashi's group is the first people he's
seen since then but long hair guy over
here doesn't trust him and he wakes up
the other two later to escape before he
wakes up elsewhere Hannah's group
reaches Tokyo but they're horrified to
see it in Ruins so they decide to head
to Mount Fuji desperate to find another
storage shelter somewhere later they
finally reach another abandoned seed
Vault but they discover a letter left
behind by one of the other teams telling
them that whoever reads this is to come
to mount yufu where they've already set
up another shelter showing this group
that old green shirt guy was right after
all the group then prepares to leave to
find more survivors meanwhile back near
Tokyo ponytail guy sits with his doggo
thinking about arashi's group and seeing
them inspires him to search for more
survivors out in the world but suddenly
he hears a terrifying scream nearby
Hannah runs for her life as she gets
chased by a dinosaur this creature gets
closer and closer to her when suddenly
ponytail guy whistles nearby then his
army of trained dogs attack this Beast
chasing it away for good Hana lays in
shock and so does ponytail guy okay I
can't even make this stuff up this is
crazy because ponytail guy here is more
of a dog lover than Owen Wilson in that
sad movie Marley and Me film the fact is
that this guy has managed to train these
dogs to come at this dinosaur is next
level it's impressive but also really
weird because while in reality the
concept of dog training isn't that
difficult to implement the most
difficult part that comes with canine
training is the interfacing with the dog
basically just like kids dogs are the
same some learn better one way While
others learn better a different way but
these puppies look to be some mix of a
wolf dog and this means that training
these beasts would be an even harder
thing to do than training a regular dog
because taming their Wild Side is
something that not anybody can just pull
off this would take a massive amount of
time dedication and skill in order to be
able to pull it off effectively and this
is something that Hana could have used
to help deduce just who the hell this
guy is despite being lost and afraid if
I was Hannah I'd take careful note of
how well this ponytail guy has trained
his dogs and could come to the
conclusion that his innate character and
personality is that of someone highly
intelligent patient and methodical
although this is the apocalypse and
trusting the wrong person could get you
killed but knowing these traits about
this stranger ponytail guy could mean
that he either could be an insanely
useful Ally or a dangerous pain in the
ass if we were to piss him off after
saving her life Hannah asks ponytail guy
to join her group after a quick shave if
he informs the group of who he has met
so far but from what he says Anna thinks
he may have run into her boyfriend which
means that he could also be alive yay
she has hope later it starts raining and
this suddenly causes Hannah to trip and
fall right into this blue slide she
doesn't think anything of it but she
doesn't realize that this will cost her
her life the next day she begins to
realize that her hand has started to
transform into something horrifying and
notices this dinosaur outside dying from
the same blue slime she fell into
ponytail guy doesn't see that she's been
infected and says that this unknown blue
slime appears every rainfall and since
there's no cure he says to stay away
from it at all costs this cements
Hannah's fate as she realizes that she's
going to die soon however not wanting to
be a burden to anyone she later leaves
the group behind and leaves a note
saying that she's gone to look for her
boyfriend but ponytail guy ain't letting
her go anywhere and eventually catches
up with her only to find that she's
gotten even more sick running out of
options he prepares to put her out of
her misery when he sees something insane
one of his dogs accidentally licks the
blue slime and the dog's mother then
immediately dunks him into seawater
curing the puppy instantly and this
gives him an idea dumping her into this
saltwater lake Hana gets instantly cured
this time giving her the actual
motivation to go find her boyfriend oh
love wins overall right elsewhere
ottershy's group on the Run find an
abandoned boat and after seeing enough
destruction and despair out on their
Adventure the group decides to head back
to their original group using this boat
once they figure out how to use it back
in Hannah's team the group continues
trekking throughout the land as
everything around them begins to get
swallowed up by this mysterious Ash and
they finally stumble onto this abandoned
Vault but this place is different from
any seed Vault they've seen before they
don't think much of it and head inside
but this move will cost someone here
their life suddenly they run into
members from Lord guys and Lord girls
Village and they meet up with tan face
guy who mentions that the recent ash
from the sky caused them to abandon
their Village forcing them to take
shelter in this scary place and this
group has no mercy and later that night
tanface guy's group kidnaps hana's team
member and the other members of tan face
guys group take Hannah's boat but Hana
turning into a fall on Independent boss
babe tries to stop them just as her
group discovers this underground farm
and here she discovers this group of
corpses and this diary she reads it and
discovers that this place was once an
apocalypse shelter for a group but due
to a deadly virus that began spreading
inside everybody was forced to
quarantine until they eventually died
but just then at the back of the Diary
Hana makes the most shocking Discovery
and sees her father's picture inside the
diary itself and oh it's a crazy secret
but just then Hana her group and tan
face guy realized that this whole place
still has the virus present and they
rushed to find Lord girl and Lord guys
group to tell them to get the hell out
of here and everybody quickly realizes
that this shelter was a death trap all
along both groups make a run for it as
Hana is reunited with her abducted
friend but as everybody leaves The Vault
they run into these strange masked men
and that was their biggest mistake the
masked men ask if anyone in the group
ran into the virus found down there and
Lord girl like a dumb dumb here says
they did suddenly this guy takes out his
piece and tries to shoot her full of
lead but tan face guy protects her
killing himself in the process which
then Awards him with the title of the
world's most dedicated Sim okay this is
batshit crazy on all types of levels the
people in this Vault basically began
killing off people due to food shortages
and they did this by literally grounding
innocent people into minced meat but to
make sure nothing went to waste they
used the minced human meat to feed the
animals and this somehow Genius of an
idea allowed this harmless parasite to
begin infecting the animals and
eventually found its way to begin
infecting humans whoever these scientist
studs are we're better prepared than
this group was and it's clear from how
they just reacted that they are ready to
survive no matter the cost but while
their assumption is that there is no
cure for this mysterious disease could
seem far-fetched in reality their
thinking is not that crazy because this
virus carried itself out in a way known
as the zoonotic spill over which is a
term used to describe the process of
pathogen transmission from wild animals
to humans similar to recent events the
crazy thing is is that the National
Library of Medicine estimates that over
60 percent of all emerging human
infectious diseases have a zoonotic
origin and have come from animal species
from HIV being introduced into the human
population from non-human primates in
the 1920s to the Middle East respiratory
virus emerging in 2012. this type of
creepy [ __ ] coming from animals first is
more common than people realize this
means that this shelter before got
destroyed should have been way more
careful due to the fact that they were
sharing an enclosed space with animals
to begin with because this bunker was
underground it's safe to assume that
these people would have kept the animals
conducive to feeding the population in
some way from pigs to chickens and cows
but the one thing that doesn't make
sense is why this bunker chose to feed
their own animals human meat at all why
would they do that animals like cows in
general are herbivores and their
digestive tract wouldn't have been
suitable to handle meat let alone human
meat and over time this act could have
increased the chances of them developing
horrifying diseases that could have
eventually infected the human population
and one of those diseases could have
been a condition known as mad cow
disease however in a ruthless
post-apocalyptic world like this one if
I was one of these scientists I wouldn't
have killed this guy since it was
clearly the stupid thing to do instead I
would have killed everybody and taken
their belongings because even if there
was food shortages killing these
survivors and eating their own flesh
would have been foolish since their
possible exposure to the virus inside
the Vault could have meant that their
flesh could have been contaminated and
since we don't know just what type of
virus is down there killing everybody on
the spot Genghis Khan style would have
been the most responsible thing to do
that these scientists could have done I
approve the mass guy says that if the
virus has already gotten to them then
it's too late so the group leaves with
more questions than answers but this
were world is too deadly to survive
alone so the two groups then joined
forces and go back to hana's Old team's
campsite but it's deserted so Village
Lords group and Hannah's group both
decide to track the strange masked men
that killed their teammate meanwhile
Natsu's group continues to learn how to
sail when suddenly they spot a body
floating in the water they discovered
that this person is called hibari and
she turns out to be pictured girl's
cousin from the other team she says that
the members from botan's group are all
in grave danger elsewhere this
black-haired kid from Hannah's team
wakes up in a strange Place run by the
masked scientists and this kid discovers
that they're using him as a lab rat for
medical experiments horrified he tries
to get away but gets caught later
Hannah's group finally catches up to the
Mad scientists and sees them using
black-haired kid as bait to lure animals
Village Lord girl then realizes that
this group of survivors are not like the
rest and have developed an advanced
village with Advanced Tech like this
hang glider knowing they need to take
this Village out Lord Village girl sends
in this person to take out the hang
glider girl and to use her as bait as
they plan out their attack later that
night we find out that this group of
scientists were actually Chosen and
trained with prior knowledge of the
world ending they were chosen to be the
leaders of this world once the
apocalypse started meanwhile Hannah's
group finally makes a plan and ponytail
guide creates a distraction before Hana
goes in to try and save black hair kick
but on the way she gets caught
red-handed and the scientists prepare to
kill her but then Hannah's team
announces to the scientists that they
have one of their teammates as hostage
buying them time but suddenly they hear
something horrifying approach them that
will change everything an army of
flesh-eating bats begins swarming
throughout the village causing panic
among the group they then all head
inside this house for safety as they try
to stop the Sea of bats from coming
inside but Hana thinks fast and throws
this bait out the window and luckily the
bats follow it saving them from being
eaten alive for now okay this is batshit
insane Hannah's team has failed to take
out these scientists and so far everyone
has been at everyone else's throat but
the fact that these hairless horrifying
creatures tried to attack us is a huge
sign because in general bats are just
terrified of us and are usually
incredibly docile creatures seriously
you can annoy the [ __ ] out of bats and
usually they're pretty tolerant However
the fact that these bats try to attack
us humans means that something is very
wrong even infected bats carrying some
sort of infection like rabbit bats as a
result of rabies are rarely aggressive
towards humans however if a bat is sick
with some sort of parasite or infection
this can cause them to behave abnormally
which can happen in a variety of ways
and to top that off we also have to
remember that these people are now in a
world that is very different from the
world we live in today it is a world
that has survived a massive meteor
strike now we don't know how much time
has passed exactly since the apocalypse
began but it's very realistic to assume
that all the rules have changed that the
evolved environment and strange animals
could be a probable result from the
nuclear mutations caused over time from
the nuclear plant meltdowns secondary to
the meteor strikes honest team is in
Japan after all and that was home to 54
nuclear reactors as of March 2020 due to
Japan's over-reliance on nuclear energy
the meteor strikes would have likely
caused massive nuclear fallout due to
the destruction of Japan's nuclear
reactors causing nuclear mutations and
genetic diversity in the country's
natural environment all of this can help
explain why these bats are batshit crazy
and nothing we've ever seen before and
this means that as opposed to killing
every single Survivor they see at this
point it may be better to set aside some
differences and join forces for now
because at this point the laws of nature
simply don't make sense anymore once the
group catches their breath from the
horrors the group of scientists demand
to know where their hand gliding team
member is but nearby in this cave Lord
Village guys determined to not let her
go when all of a sudden the army of bats
attacked them too injuring a bunch of
people in the process and injuring one
of Lord Village guy's teammates but hand
glider girl is too Noble of heart and
escapes to go get help from her team's
medic once they fix everyone up hand
glider girl mentioned that the bats have
been an issue for a long time and
everyone realizes that they'll need to
team up to fight this bigger enemy for
now much larger team than plans out
their move and begin burning all the
cave entrances and they end up smoking
the bats out just as hand glider girl
does what she does best hand gliding
stuff she Glides faster than Hanuman
hopped up on caffeine and lures the bats
away right into these hollow tree trunks
just as this guy begins banging these
wooden trees disrupting their
echolocation and forcing them to come
crashing down solving their flesh eating
bad problem for now this top scientist
right here hair dye guy then decides
that Hannah's group and all the other
survivors are now their responsibility
and hair dye guys team then begins
giving everyone jobs to help around the
village but they realize they now have
one more huge problem to deal with they
need water so hair dye guy leads a part
of the team to go look for water but one
of them separates from the group and
ends up messing around with his wood
that was his biggest mistake suddenly he
gets knocked out from behind by someone
and Falls straight into the mud later as
the group stops for a break Hannah
realizes that wood playing guy is
missing and thinks something is wrong
but hair dye guy suspiciously says that
she's just being paranoid she goes to
look for him anyway when she suddenly
hears some noise coming from this mud
swap it's wood playing guy she saves him
from nearly dying and she accuses hair
dye guy of plotting his murder but hair
dye guy denies it they almost get into a
huge fight when one of the scientists
notice Hannah's knife being the exact
same one as all these scientists use he
demands to know where she got it from
she then says that it was her father's
trusty knife showing them all a picture
of her old man but this shocks everyone
hair dye guy then reveals a terrifying
secret he then says that it was Hannah's
dad who was their supervisor back when
his team was training for the apocalypse
it was Hannah's dad that put this group
of scientists through literal Health
killing all the candidates who did it to
make it through the program taking
everything from these people causing
everyone here to hate him for it he then
says that the only reason Hana survived
the apocalypse was because of her father
and a very jealous hair dye guy freaks
his face off Hannah calls [ __ ] on
hair dye guys and says that her dad was
just a quiet government worker not a
badass mad scientist stud hair dye guys
had enough of Hannah's BS and decides to
reveal something even more horrifying he
says that it was Hannah's dad's idea to
add one member to hair dye guys group to
act as a Reaper the person chosen to be
the reaper was not told to any of them
and their sole purpose and
responsibility was to test the will of
these survivors hair tie guy says that
no one knows who the reaper is and if
they fail to survive properly the reaper
will then make sure that the weakest die
off and hair dye guy is salty about it
as hell it makes Hana do all sorts of
hard chores as punishment since he
thinks she's the Reaper which means she
must pay for what she did to him okay
this is bad this is really really bad
because right now what we've heard means
that if this group isn't careful if this
group doesn't do everything right this
Reaper will not hesitate to make sure
that we don't live to see another day in
a way this means that everyone here will
strive to pull their weight sort of like
how Village Lord girl and Village Lord
guy ran their Village through absolute
tyranny huh brilliant now while this
might sound insane as a mini Society
ruling this way does have its benefits
though as mentioned fulfilling
obligations and jobs out of fear will
ensure that many do not break the status
quo and since no one knows of the
Reaper's identity this will mean that no
one person will be at risk towards the
general public however it is a
double-edged sword as no one knowing who
the reaper is will likely mean that soon
the public will get too paranoid for its
own good and may even end up revolting
due to an unjust non-democratic Society
this is why if I was Hannah I would be
paranoid as hell about who this Reaper
was it's noted that right before Hannah
found wood playing God she asked the
group around the campfire if they had
seen him before and at that moment there
were five people present assuming that
no one else knew where wood playing guy
was since it was just these five members
who went on this water finding Mission
this means that likely one of these
people here is the culprit ponytail guy
would have had no Insidious motivation
since there would have been nothing to
gain from him killing wood plain guy
neither would there have been any
motivation for Village Lord girl unless
it was just random however the people we
still don't know anything about are
these three scientists but it would have
been too obvious for hair dye guy to try
and pull some [ __ ] since he already was
putting more attention on himself this
whole time due to his whining about
Hannah's father get over it dude also
him being the leader means that him
disappearing for no good reason would
have looked Mighty suspicious as hell
don't you think which means if I was
Hannah I would keep an eye out on this
girl and this white-haired guy as these
two right now are our biggest suspects
elsewhere arshi tries to continue
sailing their boat when it finally gets
stuck for good the group then returns to
land and end up coming across an old
village that they don't realize belonged
to Village Lord guy and Village Lord
girl and here Natsu discovers the note
left behind from Hana to her boyfriend
who she finds out is arashi and she's
not too happy about it she does prepare
to give arushi the letter though when
suddenly meatball hair girl and glasses
guys show up and tell them that botan's
group is in trouble they go to rescue
them and it is here that Natsu finally
gives arashi the letter belonging to his
long-lost girlfriend finally letting him
know that she's alive back at Hannah's
team she prepares to leave the group
when she gets summoned to go on one last
Dangerous Mission with votan's group and
the scientists to look for water deep in
this terrifying cave but that's when
white-haired guy decides to split up
with Hana and this girl and he makes
Hana rope down this Cliff face suddenly
white-haired guy takes out his knife and
begins cutting Hannah's rope he says
that Hannah's presence in the group has
made their leader hair dye guy mentally
unstable and that she must die in order
for the group as a whole to survive
Hannah begins freaking out and she finds
out that it was white-haired guy who
tried to kill wood playing guy earlier
he must be the reaper white-haired guy
then cuts the Rope and she falls to her
death okay did this not just prove my
point that everyone during the
apocalypse are real turd blossoms but
Hana here could have ensured that she
would have been much harder to kill if
she had enough foresight and common
sense in the first place she just had
gotten word that someone had tried to
kill wood plan guy earlier and got
informed that this group of scientists
had a Reaper within their group this
information alone should have made Hana
way more cautious as this means that
whoever tried to kill wood playing guy
wasn't some random schmuck but a
well-trained killer and even if we
didn't know who the killer was this
whole time Hannah already knew that this
group of scientists were trained to
survive as this was their mission
objective therefore it would not have
been crazy to assume that they would
have been prepared to kill anyone who
got in their way of their mission
objective especially since everyone here
is a group of well-trained killers and
the fact that the scientists knew that
was the daughter of their instructor
means that there would have been
probable cause to think that her
appearance within this group would have
made some people like hair dye guy go
crazy therefore she should have known
that as soon as she opened her mouth
about her father and saw the reaction
she was a Flight Risk just waiting to be
taken out and also Hana should have
known better than to just separate from
her original group and to have placed
her life in the hands of these
well-trained killers Reaper or not
Hannah got too complacent and too buoy
crazy thinking about her boo and in the
end paid the ultimate price for her
foolishness love disgusting Hannah wakes
up somehow not dead which is a shock
terrified she tries to not panic just as
she hears the sound of water nearby but
she bumps into hair dye guy who looks
shocked to see her Hana tells him to not
come any closer and begins freaking out
and suddenly trips into this River she
screams for her life as everyone hears
her and comes running to save her but
the current is too strong and she knows
that her time is almost up she yells out
to her teammates that white hair guy was
the one who tried to kill her and would
playing guy freaking everyone one out
here including hair dye guy just as she
gets sucked into this Whirlpool ending
her life for good ponytail guy freaks
his tits off and meets up back with the
group outside where he attacks white
hair guy mourning the loss of one good
friend and one less Survivor the group
tries to not cry their faces off because
they can't be wusses and they prepare to
survive in Hannah's memory as they carry
on their Adventure in this
post-apocalyptic World unknowing of what
Horrors they'll soon have to face and if
you don't want to
of course didn't like it don't get check
out the how to be playlist down below